[Musique]
nous sommes ici comme l'a dit louis à le
fbi a le fbi tous les ans 1700 avocats
sont formés un avocat sur deux est passé
dans ses murs et je vais même dire une
chose il ya une avocate qui passait dans
seigneur que je connais très bien
il s'agit de ma fille cadette je suis
très fier elle va prêter serment dans
une semaine et donc le soir à la maison
vous savez de quoi on parle on parle de
l'avenir de la justice ça me concerne
donc à deux titres professionnels et
personnels alors je suis très fier mais
en même temps j'ai une pointe de
tristesse et de perplexité
mais tout simplement parce que ce
qu'elle a entendu dire sur la ligue
altec sur le métier de son papa c'est
que les entrepreneurs de la ligue altec
sont vus ici ou été vu jusqu'à
maintenant comme des charognards du
droit et là j'avoue que ça m'a mis dans
un océan de perplexité un peu de
tristesse mais aussi de l'inquiétude
parce que je me suis dit mais quelle est
cette perception que ces juristes ont de
ce qui est en train de se passer autour
d'eux et qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire pour les aider à ouvrir leur
esprit les gaffes à google apple
facebook amazon microsoft et bien des
livres des services à un humain sur deux
à peu près il délivre ses services avec
autant de succès parce qu'ils ont su
penser des services sympa des services
simples des services intuitif des
services qu'on a tous envie d'utiliser
et qu'on utilise tous ils ont une
démarche 12h centric
c'est à dire qu'ils sont posés la
question de mais qui est cet utilisateur
qu'est ce qu'il fait de quoi at il envie
et là c'est ça qu'on va lui fournir
et quand on regarde la perspective que
cela donne et bien c'est que les gaffes
à elles sont en train d'absorber petit à
petit tout un tas de moments de notre
vie du matin jusqu'au soir c'était
l'information c'est la manière de se
relier aux autres les réseaux sociaux
c'est demain la finance les transports
l'organisation de la ville
l'assurance mêmes et même les missions
de l'état les missions les plus les plus
importantes de l'état la monnaie et la
justice et on se dit mais messieurs de
la justice est ce que vous vous rendez
compte de ce qui est en train de se
passer est ce que vous vous rendez
compte que le justiciable n'est plus
celui que vous pensiez avoir en face de
vous il est connecté il est digital il
est fluide il va vite il vote avec ses
doigts les justiciables en effet vous
moi dans la plein de choses devant nous
quand on veut parler de droit et de
justice
il ya de plus en plus d'avocats il ya
des sites sur internet sur lesquels on
peut faire de l'automédication en fait
il ya tellement de choses qu'on est con
et un petit peu paumé et puis d'un autre
côté vous avez un garde des sceaux qui a
dit en avril 2016 est la justice est une
institution en faillite une institution
en faillite
les tribunaux sont engorgés la france
est régulièrement coûts et au pilori en
europe pour les dénis de justice qu'elle
inflige à ses à ses citoyens
les procédures sont onéreuses elles sont
longues et on se dit mais attendez vous
êtes très fort mais sur les juristes
vous êtes un des budgets les plus
importants de l'état vous réfléchissez
beaucoup vous proposer des des réformes
pour moderniser la justice mais ça a pas
l'air de marcher alors je me dis mais
pourquoi est ce que ça ne marche pas ou
en tout cas si je ne sais pas dire
pourquoi je propose d'essayer autre
chose c'est d'avoir une vision ou une
approche de la modernisation de la
justice qui serait penché d'une façon
beaucoup plus direct sur vous sur moi
sur le justiciable
clairement je suis en train de vous dire
que j'aimerais qu'on réfléchisse à une
justice moderne en abordant comme les
gaffes à abordent leur business avec des
utilisateurs en pensant injustice
justiciables saintrick alors pour aider
les juristes pour nous aider nous tous à
réfléchir de façon justiciables
saintrick
je propose de lancer un premier défi à
la communauté du droit et ce premier
défi c'est comment rendre le droit
instantanément accessibles parce qu'en
fait pour vous pour moi on ne rencontre
le droit que quand quelque chose va de
travers quand on a un problème on a un
litige
on est un peu en panique on est stressé
il ya des choses en jeu on perd sa
lucidité
donc comment résoudre cet accès aux
droits de façon instantanée et bien je
propose de regarder ce que font nos amis
de d'amazon amazon une place de marché
universel ont vent tourne achète tout
sur amazon des services des matelas de
la nourriture des livres est une jungle
de d'offres et bien amazon à penser à
quelque chose que je trouve briand le
once tête bail
vous savez ce petit bouton qui est à
droite de l'écran je clique et en un
clic le produit choisi le produit est
empaqueté le produit est étiqueté le
produit est envoyé le produit payé je
vous rassure et le produit mais livrés
et bien moi je rêve d'un one step accès
à la loi j'ai un accident juridique je
suis en panique
je suis au bord de l'autoroute de la vie
eh bien j'aimerais avoir ce one step
accès à la loi qui me permettrait
d'accéder aux services d'urgences
juridique
je vais vous proposer un deuxième défi
un défi sur le litige les litiges
ça nous accable ça nous arrive trop
souvent le conflit la dispute
eh bien je propose de regarder nos amis
de ib paraît surprenant ib ib aux états
unis c'est une communauté de 200
millions de personnes des acheteurs et
des vendeurs des boutiques des
individuels c'est plusieurs milliards de
transactions je parle dans chiffres
parlent en nombre de transactions des
milliards de transactions tous les ans
et donc des occasions de litige
bien évidemment énorme ça se compte en
millions en dizaines de millions
et bien ib a pensé à un bouton magique
c'est le one step résolution c'est un
bouton qui permet en cas de litige
d'avoir accès à un tribunal d'une
plateforme de médiation ou virtuels ou
avec un médiateur qui permet de résoudre
instantanément ont très vite de litige
et bien au travers de ce tribunal de la
consommation virtuel les gens de ib ont
traité en 2015 60 millions de 4,60
millions de litiges 60 millions de mini
procès eh bien je rêve de ce bouton one
step résolutions qui en cas d'accident
de conflits me permettrait d'accéder à
un référent un arbitre un médiateur une
plateforme en ligne et de résoudre vite
instantanément où très vite malgré tout
de façon gratuite ou pas cher mon litige
j'ai un troisième défi en tête ce que je
suis quelqu'un qui aime les défis
le troisième défi c'est comment avoir
des outils de pilotage de ma vie
juridique et quand on regarde
aujourd'hui sur internet
il y a beaucoup de technologies qui sont
à notre disposition qui nous permettrait
de relever ce défi je pense au big data
je pense à l'intelligence artificielle
je pense aux machine learning
ce sont des technologies des techniques
qui sont déjà massivement utilisés par
les gaffes à l'oral est loin du très
précise c'est pouvoir faire de la
prédictibilité du comportement vous êtes
à peine rentré sur le site qu'on sait
déjà qu'on va pouvoir penser vous
proposez vous orientez vous vendre
quelque chose avec beaucoup d'efficacité
amazon fait 45% de son business sur la
recommandation
et bien moi je rêve d'un one step
pilotage juridique qui me permettrait
d'avoir accès aux ressources d'un legal
analytics connaissez tous google
analytics
et bien moi je rêve de ce legal
très fin très pertinent très sérieux
très efficace et très personnalisé qui
me permettrait de piloter ma trajectoire
juridique de prendre des décisions de
mesurer des risques bref d'organiser ma
vie en pleine connaissance voilà j'ai
d'autres idées de défis mais voilà les
trois défis principaux que je voudrais
lancer à mes collègues dans cette
industrie
quand je dis mes collègues dans
l'industrie je pense aux juristes je
pense à vous tous à moi-même et je pense
aux ligues alltech parce que si on n'y
fait pas attention il y à un espèce de
mouvement très doux très sourd mais très
fort qui fait que des pans entiers de
droit sont en train de basculer dans des
sphères que le mode ne contrôlons plus
en vérité vous avez des entreprises à
but lucratif dont on ne sait pas bien si
les contrôles mais qui sont en train au
travers de techniques de relation client
jus clients je ne veux pas qu'on traite
bien mais au travers de la relation
client au travers d'une science d'un art
de l'expérience utilisateur de capter
tout ce qui relève beaucoup de choses
qui relèvent aujourd'hui du droit si on
ne fait pas attention demain le droit
sera anglo saxons et sera délivrée par
les gaffes à je vais répéter demain si
on ne fait pas attention le droit sera
anglo saxons et sera délivrée par les
gars fin je vais vous pouvez linkedin
linkedin superbe réseau professionnel
fut membre
c'est un réseau dans lequel de plus en
plus de services sont offerts à
l'employeur à l'employer à tout un
chacun celui qui cherche du boulot et
bien demain demain matin linkedin sera
plus efficace que pôle emploi pour
trouver du travail
et comme linkedin ils sont malins va
proposer demain après-midi des services
pour gérer le contrat de travail en un
clic un clic contrat de travail mais ça
veut dire que demain soir
le droit du travail sera dit dans
linkedin ça ne suffit pas comme preuve
je vais rajouter une deuxième preuve
facebook
donc si je suis membre de facebook est
bien facebook s'est retrouvé au centre
d'un certain nombre de procédures dans
un domaine très privé des divorces dans
un certain nombre de divorces aux états
unis mais pas que facebook est utilisé
comme aimant des éléments de preuve pour
établir de l'infidélité conjugale et
voyait des gens assez bête qui se sont
priant en photo en vacances avec leurs
maîtresses ou leur amant eh bien ça
servi de preuve pour pouvoir établir un
divorce aux dépens de celui qui a pris
des vacances
eh bien demain dans le droit de la
famille sera dit dans facebook
et comme demain le droit de la
consommation sera dit dans amazon mais
tout ça ça va arriver demain si si si on
ne se bat pas et tout mon plaidoyer là
moi je rêve d'une justice qui se
penserait commun comme une ressource à
la disposition des citoyens à la
disposition de la société
je la rave comme une méta plateforme de
ressources du droit du code accessible
qui serait interconnectables avec la
société civile qui serait connectable
avec des services publics avec des
services privés des services qui
seraient capables d'être très innovant
d'être très agile de pouvoir délivrer du
droit sans friction facilement tout le
temps et en fait je rêve d'une justice
qui serait capable d'accompagner aussi
bien et voire même mieux que les gaffes
à cette évolution civilisationnel que
nous avons qui est un risque qui est une
opportunité
en tout cas c'est un fait on passe d'une
civilisation y est rare chic pyramidale
très organisés à une civilisation très
organique où je parle à mon voisin je
parle n'importe qui sans passer par des
tiers d'autorité ou des tiers de
confiance
cette société organique c'est celle dans
laquelle nous sommes en train de vivre
chaque jour un peu plus
et si la justice ne suit pas ce
mouvement et puis en vérité c'est pas
que les tribunaux sont engorgés
c'est que des tribunaux seront désertés
et donc je pense à une civilisation
organique avec une justice qui
s'accompagnait un citoyen un citoyen qui
sera beaucoup plus responsable dans ses
choix qui pourra organiser sa vie
juridique qui pourra avoir accès à du
droit auprès d'un organisme public privé
peu importe il aura le choix de
l'institution il aura le choix du
tribunal il aura le choix de la manière
de gérer sa vie juridique et il aura non
seulement ce choix mais il aura cette
responsabilité et il pourra se penser
non plus comme objet de droit mais comme
sujet de droit merci
[Applaudissements]